I don't know when it happened in the
history,
but we become obsessed with the concept
of having a vision.
Right?
And there's this overwhelming pressure
on entrepreneurs or any of us for that
matter,
that we all have to have a vision.
People even ask us.
So what's your vision?
What's your vision in your job?
What kind of vision do you want to build
or follow?
And at the end of the day,
we're not all visionaries.
Um,
we don't all have big change.
The world's kind of visions.
And even if we have some sense of it,
very few of us are really capable or
able of articulating that vision and
words so clearly than others could
imagine that same world that we imagine
sometimes it's just a feeling.
And so I think it puts an unfair stress
and an unfair burden on all of us that
we have to have a vision.
I don't know.
I just want to go to work and be happy
and feel like my life and my work is
valuable.
Do I need more than that?
But I do believe we have to find
division.
We have to have direction.
We have to have a north star.
We have to know where we're going.
It doesn't have to be the direction we
set.
It can be the direction that somebody
else said.
So it's very important for us to find a
leader or find a company or find a
vision in whom we believe so that our
work is contributing to building that.
So,
you know,
and the civil rights era,
some may not have been able to clearly
articulate the vision that they
imagined,
but Martin Luther King did.
And so for the rest of us,
we said,
I'm following him.
I'm following that vision.
That's the vision I believe in.
And that's the point.
We should all find division that we
believe in.
We should find common direction and then
that vision can become ours.
But we don't have to invent it and we
don't have to originate it.
But we absolutely have the
responsibility to find a person,
company,
or other,
uh,
entity out there,
other person or organization that puts
in towards the vision that we absolutely
believe in and would commit our blood
and sweat and tears to help build.
If we do not have that fire in our
belly,
the way we go about igniting it is not
actually to set out on a journey of self
discovery and do everything by
ourselves,
but rather to ask for help.
The whole point is that we are better
together.
I,
I'm,
I sort of joke about the fact that
there's an entire section in the
bookshop called self help,
but there's no section in the bookshop
called help others.
At the end of the day,
it's not about how I can find the job of
my dreams.
It's the question is,
is how can I help my friends find a
career of endless fulfillment.
It's not about how I can lose 10 pounds.
It's how can I help my friend that
somebody I love live a healthy
lifestyle.
And the amazing thing is is that when
we're willing to ask for help or when
we're willing to set ourselves out there
to help others,
that in itself helps us solve our own
problems.
So the irony is,
is the way to ignite the fire in our
bellies is to help others ignite the
fire.
And there is an in so doing,
we will find the thing that excites us.
People often ask me for good examples of
vision,
you know,
and uh,
I don't believe vision should be
something that is if theorial it
shouldn't be something that lives in our
imaginations,
I believe visions and positionings or
whatever you wanna call them.
I like to call it the why.
And it's why we get out of bed every
morning.
It's why our organization exists.
And one of my favorite expressions of
the why is the declaration of
independence.
You know,
why does America Exist?
While we actually declared it,
we actually declared why we needed our
own country,
why we needed to separate from Great
Britain.
And we said,
because we had a simple belief,
we believe that all men were created
equal,
that every single one of us was
entitled,
endowed with these unalienable rights
amongst which include life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
In other words,
a north star was set for this country.
And when we are at our natural best,
we are working hard to provide equality
for all women's suffrage,
civil rights,
gay,
gay rights.
You know the ability for everybody to go
to school,
the ability for everybody,
every child have a doctor.
This is what,
when we are at our natural best,
when we're trying to figure it out,
none of the systems are perfect,
but my goodness,
when we try hard,
we're trying to advance the equality of
all that is when America is actually
America and we know that to be the case
because it's not up for debate.
It's because it was written down for us
and so great organizations,
they should also declare why we need
them to exist because it certainly ain't
in their product because none of them
have a product that's that special that
we have to have it and we can't get it
from someone else.
And even if they did,
it's temporary and that's the point.
The product ain't it.
It's the declaration.
It's the reason why we need you to
exist.
It's your idealism and your ambition for
the world in which you operate,
that you hope to advance.
Thomas Jefferson said himself the
declaration of independence.
The statement that he had was for the
whole world,
but America would take it upon
themselves to lead,
to try to be the experiment.
So too should be the visions of
companies,
the visions that we have should be for
every company,
for everyone,
but we will take it upon ourselves to
make our organization the example of
what great looks like.
I love the declaration of independence,
and it is written in such a perfect form
to,
it doesn't start by complaining.
It starts by idealizing,
and then it gets into all of the things
that are in the way the of the,
of this ideal.
And that's what we set out to overcome.